.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Sanfte Musik *
(Frau) Es war keine Idee,
sondern eine Obsession.
Ich muss der ganzen Welt zeigen,
wie man eine Beziehung
mit einem Oktopus haben kann.
Eine liebevolle Begegnung
auf Augenhöhe zwischen zwei Wesen,
wie sie unterschiedlicher
nicht sein könnten.
Diese Vision lockt Nathalie Küttel
in die Arme eines Oktopus.
Ich habe sie bei diesem Vorhaben
acht Monate begleitet.
Die Institution ShanjuLab bei Gimel
im Kanton Waadt.
Ein Hof mit einer besonderen Mission:
Im Zentrum steht das friedliche
Zusammenleben von Tier und Mensch.
Rund zehn Artisten und 80 Tiere
leben hier
und erforschen die Präsenz von Tieren
im Theater.
Das ShanjuLab ist Nathalies
Arbeitgeber und zweites Zuhause.
Hier
gibt sie Theater- und Zirkuskurse
und steht als Schauspielerin
regelmässig auf der Bühne.
Beziehungen
haben mich schon immer interessiert.
Die Beziehung Mensch-Mensch,
Tier-Tier oder Mensch-Tier.
Ich denke, im Theater erforscht man,
wie Beziehungen in der Welt
gelebt werden.
Das ist der Punkt,
der mich interessiert.
Ich bin zu Shanju gekommen,
um zu arbeiten,
weil man mit Tieren auf der Bühne
arbeitet, aber keine Dressur macht.
Seit 14 Jahren
rückt Nathalie ihre starke Bindung
mit Tieren ins Scheinwerferlicht.
Z.B. im Stück "Yoga-Dog".
Oder im Stück "Brennende Liebe".
* Fröhliche Musik *
Jetzt will die Westschweizerin
ausgerechnet mit einem Oktopus
auf die Bühne.
Das Schwierigste: In einem Aquarium
für Kraken muss alles stimmen -
Temperatur, Anteile an Salz, Nitrite,
Nitrate, Phosphor und Bakterien.
Das ist Wasser mit Salz.
Da hat es noch keine Bakterien drin.
Seit zwei Tagen
kommen mit dem Bio-Filter ...
... Bakterien rein ...
... damit das Wasser lebendig wird.
In den kleinen Röhrchen
leben Bakterien.
Ich muss aufpassen, dass sie immer
Sauerstoff und Wasser haben.
Vor sechs Jahren löste
ein Dokumentarfilm über Oktopusse
Nathalies Obsession aus.
Daraufhin reiste sie nach Napoli
ins Meeresbiologische Institut
und lernte die Meerestiere
erstmals näher kennen.
Für sie nicht namenlose Forschungs-
objekte, sondern Persönlichkeiten.
Das ist das Meeresbiologische
Institut in Napoli.
Als ich ankam,
hatten alle Oktopusse eine Nummer.
Im Labor gibt man keine Namen.
Das Erste, was ich gemacht habe:
allen Oktopussen einen Namen geben.
Ich taufte sie
Sensimilia, Bernard und Sybille.
Dann habe ich eine Woche
von einem Biologen gelernt.
Er hat mit mir gearbeitet
und mir gezeigt,
wie man Wasser kontrolliert
und Essen vorbereitet.
Ich habe von ihm gelernt.
Dann ging er in die Ferien
und ich blieb alleine
mit all den Oktopussen.
Aber ich war nie alleine.
Ich habe einfach acht Stunden am Tag
mit ihnen gespielt
und den Kopf ins Wasser gesteckt.
Alle, die im Labor arbeiteten,
haben mich komisch angeschaut.
Zurück in der Schweiz
hat sie sich mit ihrem Team fünf
Jahre auf das Projekt vorbereitet.
Jetzt sind sie bereit, zwei Oktopusse
in die Schweiz zu holen.
Ich freue mich ganz fest
und bin auch etwas nervös.
Ich glaube, es ist so,
wie wenn man ein Kind kriegt.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich das sagen soll.
Für mich ist es fast dasselbe.
Ein Milliliter.
Fünf Monate vor der Theaterpremiere.
Anfang September 2020 begleite ich
Nathalie nach Südfrankreich.
Auf der Reise erzählt mir Nathalie
von ihrer Faszination
für die Oktopusse.
Sie sehen die Welt
auf eine andere Art.
Sie sind sehr sensibel.
Sie haben neun Hirne,
drei Herzen ...
... und v.a.
können sie ihre Hautfarbe ändern,
um sich zu verstecken
und anderen Angst zu machen.
Sie können nicht nur die Farbe
verändern, sondern auch die Form.
Und sie können Farben annehmen,
die es in der Natur so nicht gibt.
Intelligenz
als Schlüssel zum Überleben.
Oktopusse können planvoll handeln
und schnell lernen.
Das ist für Weichtiere einzigartig.
Sète
an der französischen Mittelmeerküste.
Nathalie und ihr Team treffen
den Berufsfischer Eric Bellone.
Einer der wenigen,
der nicht mit der Harpune fischt
und so die Oktopusse nicht verletzt.
Ich töte sie nicht.
Sie leben ziemlich lange
ausserhalb des Wassers.
Ich transportiere sie lebendig
zum Fischmarkt.
Das ist das Boot,
auf dem ich arbeite.
Und hier sind die Oktopusse.
Den weissen da haben sie gefressen.
Er ist ganz ruhig.
Ich sehe die Tentakel.
Ihr habt also
euren Kollegen gefressen?
Die sind ziemlich gross.
Ich dachte, die seien kleiner.
Salut, les loulous.
Die Kraken
werden in den Fässern transportiert.
Die Schauspielerin
vergleicht den Salzgehalt des Meeres
mit den Werten ihres Aquariums.
Der Salzgehalt ist bei 38 %.
Das ist verrückt.
Der ist normalerweise bei 35.
Sorgfältig!
Nicht, dass er Tinte spritzt. Super.
Er wollte nicht bei mir bleiben.
Der hat seinen Kollegen gefressen.
Achtung!
Macht euch keine Sorgen!
Für diese zwei Tiere
hält das Schicksal
eine spezielle Wende bereit.
Anstelle des Fischmarktes,
wo sie für 20 Euro verkauft würden,
wartet eine Theaterkarriere.
Ich glaube, wir haben alles.
Wir sind verrückt.
Voilà.
Là.
Ich schliesse wegen der Klimaanlage.
Klimaanlage auf die höchste Stufe.
Hast du einen Pullover?
Okay, gleich.
Putain!
Ich hoffe, sie überleben.
Es war ihnen heiss da im Hafen.
Der Transport in die Schweiz
ist der erste Härtetest
für Nathalie und ihr Team.
Immer wieder
schauen sie nach den Kraken.
Oh, er ist ganz weiss.
Geht es ihm gut oder nicht?
Ich weiss nicht.
Ich will nicht reinfassen.
Hat er Tinte gespritzt?
- Nein, nein. Das ist es nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob er Angst vor mir hat.
Wieso?
- Weil er weiss ist.
Wenn du ihnen Angst machst,
werden sie weiss.
Jetzt ist es wieder besser.
Er nimmt wieder Farbe an.
Ich glaube,
ich habe ihm Angst gemacht.
Bis die Weichtiere in den Aquarien
sind, bleibt die Lage angespannt.
Noch vor Ankunft in Gimel
wurden die Tiere getauft:
Sie heissen Agde und Sète -
wie ihre Heimatorte.
Die spritzen uns gleich an.
- Sag das nicht.
Wenn alles klappt,
bringt Nathalie die Kraken nach
einer Europatournee zurück ins Meer.
Wie viel Zeit dafür bleibt,
ist jedoch ungewiss.
Kraken werden
höchstens zwei bis drei Jahre alt.
Okay, machen wir kurz die Analysen.
Nur die Sonden?
- Einfach pH-Wert und Temperatur.
Jetzt müssen sie
das Wasser des Transports
dem Wasser der Aquarien angleichen -
fünf Stunden lang.
Ich habe das Gefühl, mitten
in einer Herzoperation zu stehen.
Das Wasser ist bei 8-14.
8-17.
Warte, warte, warte.
Dann endlich der grosse Moment:
1'600 Saugnäpfe auf Entdeckungstour.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Voilà.
Yes!
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Das ist das Schönste.
Für mich ist das
das Schönste im Leben.
Schau mal.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Gute Nacht.
* Sanfte Musik *
Hallo.
Guten Morgen.
Wie hast du geschlafen?
Ich bin viermal aufgewacht,
um nach ihnen zu schauen.
Wir müssen da oben besser zumachen.
Es hat eine kleine Spalte.
Das machen wir heute.
Wenn ich nur ein Geräusch hörte,
hatte ich Angst,
dass sie rauskommen.
Dann kam ich, um zu kontrollieren.
Aber sonst habe ich gut geschlafen.
Siehst du das? Der hat zwei Farben.
Schau, schau.
Ganz langsam.
Er hat wohl im Aquarium
etwas gesehen.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Er hat wohl etwas gesehen.
Etwas zum Jagen oder so.
Andererseits ist er ganz ruhig.
Ich weiss nicht, was er gesehen hat.
Oktopusse sind in der Regel
schüchtern und leben einsam.
Trotzdem sind sie neugierig.
Bis zu den ersten Bühnenproben
bleibt ein Monat.
Zeit für Nathalie, Agde und Sète
sich näherzukommen.
Das Elternhaus in Renens.
Ich begleite die 46-Jährige
zu ihrer Mutter,
um herauszufinden, wie das
mit den Tieren angefangen hat.
Hallo.
- Hallo. Kommt rein!
Es ist kalt.
- Ja.
Möchtest du einen Tee?
- Ja, gerne. Es ist kalt.
Nathalies Eltern
haben beruflich Tiere präpariert.
Tot oder lebendig: Tiere waren
in ihrer Kindheit allgegenwärtig.
Da waren wir in Guarda
in den Ferien.
Ah, là, voilà. Das ist Nathalie.
Sie wollte immer ein Hund sein.
Das ist wahr.
- Sie hat uns halb verrückt gemacht.
Dann haben wir sie
halt am Pfosten angebunden.
So war sie der Hund.
Wir gaben ihr einen Teller am Boden
und dann ass sie halt am Boden.
Dann hatte sie noch Kaninchen.
- Ah ja.
Was für ein Mädchen war Nathalie?
Puh!
Manchmal ein etwas mühsames.
Aber herzig. Sie hatte immer
viele verrückte Ideen.
Sie wollte immer Zirkus spielen
und ... Voilà.
Wenn sie morgens Käse essen sollte,
fand sie in der Schule ein Senkloch,
aus dem Ratten kamen
und brachte den Gala-Käse
den Ratten.
Ja, die Ratte war riesig,
das weiss ich noch.
Fast so dick wie eine Katze.
Ich legte das Gala-Stück hin,
versteckte mich
und dann kam sie raus zum Fressen.
Ja, nein. Voilà. Ja ...
Was wolltest du immer dressieren?
Heuschrecken.
Ja, es hatte im Chalet
so grosse Heuschrecken.
Seit einem Monat
leben die zwei Kraken im ShanjuLab.
Verblüfft beobachte ich
die Beziehungsfortschritte
zwischen Agde, Sète und Nathalie.
Täglich spielen sie mehrere Stunden.
Man sieht,
dass wir uns besser kennen.
Sie kommen schneller zu uns
und haben keine Angst mehr.
Sie bleiben einfach gerne
so auf der Hand ...
Sie bleiben einfach so
und können so spüren.
Wir sind beides lebendige Tiere,
die sich kennenlernen.
Wir ...
... schauen einfach,
was beim Spielen passiert.
Es ist lustig:
Er hält den Ball nicht immer.
Er geht ihn holen ...
... nimmt ihn und gibt ihn zurück.
Bum.
Hopp.
Ich finde,
es ist wie eine Diskussion ...
... mit einem Kollegen,
aber einfach ...
... anders.
300 l umfasst die Spielwiese
der beiden Kraken.
Die Finanzierung
der professionellen Anlage
wurde dank der Zusammenarbeit
mit dem Théâtre de Vidy möglich.
Im Januar findet
die ausverkaufte Premiere statt.
Noch vier Monate.
Zeit für die erste Bühnenprobe.
Stefan Kaegi führt Regie.
Mit einem Lichtkonzept, Videoprojek-
tionen, Tonaufnahmen und Livemusik
inszeniert das Team die Begegnung
zwischen Nathalie und dem Oktopus.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Was während einer Vorstellung
passiert, ist ungewiss.
Probier mal,
ein bisschen mit ihm zu spielen!
Ein bisschen nach rechts.
Da hast du ein bisschen Licht.
Schau mal,
ob er deine Hand verfolgt.
Wenn er etwas macht ...
... geht es gut.
Aber ...
... manchmal
bewegt er sich stark ...
... und ich weiss nicht,
was er sieht.
Die Fenster machen wie eine ...
... Spiegelung?
- Ja. Darauf müssen wir achten.
Ein Monat bis zur Premiere.
Wie jeden Tag fährt Nathalie
zu ihren achtarmigen Bühnenpartnern.
Sie lebt in einer Beziehung.
Kinder hat sie keine,
zumindest keine richtigen.
Es ist fast wie Kinder zu haben.
Man muss immer da sein.
Aber es ist schön. Es macht Spass.
Es ist viel, aber ...
Drei Stunden pro Tag sind schon ...
Man muss schon ...
Zuerst muss man Tests machen,
dann alles putzen:
Filter putzen, Skimmer wechseln,
die Bakterien ...
Ich wechsle jeden Tag
die 30 l Wasser des Aquariums,
damit es wieder frisches Wasser hat.
Die Schauspielerin tut alles,
damit es den Tieren
so gut wie möglich geht.
Jeden Tag stellt sie
die zwei Intelligenzbestien
vor ein neues Rätsel.
- Das ist neu.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob er es aufmachen kann.
Wir werden es sehen.
Es ist das erste Mal ...
... dass er das kriegt.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Er hat schon Kraft.
Für Nathalie
unzählige Arbeitsstunden,
für die Oktopusse
sieben Monate Freiheitsentzug.
Das Projekt hat seinen Preis.
Der soll sich auszahlen.
Auf der ganzen Welt werden
tonnenweise Tintenfisch gegessen.
Ich glaube, wenn wir zeigen ...
... wie sensibel und intelligent ...
... ein Tier ist, das
so weit von uns entfernt lebt,
kann das allen Tintenfischen helfen.
Jetzt kann ich kurz Staub saugen.
Ja ...
Sonst ist es kompliziert.
Hat er es geschafft?
Hehe, siehst du?
Bravo.
Er hat sich Zeit genommen,
weil es neu war.
Hast du manchmal auch Zweifel daran,
ob es richtig ist,
dieses Projekt zu machen,
weil die Oktopusse
besser in Freiheit wären?
Ja, das ist eine wichtige Frage.
Ja ...
Äh ...
Manchmal frage ich mich schon,
ob das, was wir machen,
gut ist oder nicht.
Ich habe viele Fragen dazu.
Aber ich sehe auch, dass der Oktopus
mit uns sein und spielen will.
Er hat zu essen.
In der Natur:
Jedes Mal, wenn ein Oktopus ...
... sein Zuhause verlässt ...
... kann sein Leben enden.
Möglicherweise
findet er nichts zu essen.
Was ist besser? Freiheit
oder jeden Tag essen zu können?
Vielleicht ist es auch besser,
hier zu sein.
Es ist wie im Hotel:
Wir haben Essen
und spielen mit ihnen.
Äh ...
Ich kann nicht ...
... in seinem Körper sein.
Ich würde gerne ein Oktopus sein
und sehen, wie das ist.
Er hat diese zwei Augen.
Wenn du eine Beziehung hast,
kommen die aus dem Wasser.
Wenn du im Wasser bist
und nach oben schaust ...
... siehst du eine Spiegelung.
Sie gehen weiter als die Spiegelung,
um dich zu sehen.
Für mich ist das ...
Ja ...
Sie machen den Weg zu mir
und ich auch zu ihnen.
Ich gehe auch ins Wasser.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Was ich schön finde:
Wenn wir ins Wasser gehen,
nehmen wir Luft
und atmen sozusagen in der Reserve.
Und wenn der Oktopus rauskommt,
nimmt er Wasser ...
... und kommt raus.
Er atmet im Wasser.
Wir können
nur eine kurze Zeit zusammen sein.
Wie in der Liebe:
nur ein kurzer Moment.
Er will immer,
dass ich in sein Zuhause komme,
aber das kann ich nicht.
Ich würde das gerne,
aber ich kann es nicht.
Ich kann nicht im Wasser leben.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Januar 2021
im Théâtre de Vidy bei Lausanne.
Trotz Lockdown
findet heute die Premiere statt.
Ist gut?
- Ja.
Für die Vorstellungen
wechseln sich die Oktopusse ab.
Heute kommt Agde zum Zug.
Spüren Oktopusse die Nervosität?
Ja, sicher.
Man muss ruhig bleiben.
Ja, wir haben gespürt,
dass sie es schon spüren.
Merci.
- Il est motivé.
Wieso macht er das?
Einfach zum Spielen.
Sie spritzen gerne mit Wasser.
Wenn sie dich kennen,
spritzen sie dich an.
Oui, mon beau.
* Lachen *
Er gibt mir einen Kuss.
Das Wasser ist kalt.
Salut. Non!
* Lachen *
Bon.
Ein bisschen Konzentration.
Hey, wir müssen auf die Bühne. Komm!
Macht er das, weil er Spass hat?
- Ja, er will spielen.
Er macht das schon gerne.
Wegen der Corona-Massnahmen
ist die Aufführung
ausschliesslich für Veranstalter.
Nur gerade 20 Personen
werden Zeugen der Weltpremiere:
ein Oktopus im Theater.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Wenn es beginnt,
bin ich wie im Meer.
Es ist so, als ob ich
unter Wasser atmen könnte.
Es ist etwas sehr Ruhiges.
Etwas Richtiges.
Ich spiele mit ihm
und das ist eigentlich das Wichtige.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ich bin einfach da.
Und wenn ich ruhig bin,
ist er auch ruhig.
Ich habe akzeptiert,
dass vielleicht nichts passiert.
Und wenn nichts passiert,
dann ist es so.
Ich denke, das macht es interessant.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Que je suis l'autre de l'autre.
* Ruhige Musik *
Nach 75 Minuten erwache ich
aus einer Fantasiewelt.
* Applaus *
Zwölf Vorstellungen
zeigt das Théâtre de Vidy.
Dann beendet Corona die Europatournee
und das Projekt vorzeitig.
Zwei Wochen später treffe ich
Nathalie aufgelöst bei ihr zu Hause.
Ja ...
... wir wollten sie
bereits freilassen,
aber es ist kompliziert mit COVID.
Man kann nicht nach Frankreich
und darf nicht in der Nacht fahren.
Wir wollten gehen,
aber es war zu kompliziert.
Für Agde geht die Warterei zu lange.
Er stirbt in der Schweiz.
Die Schuld war immer bei uns.
Wir haben so viel diskutiert,
ob wir das dürfen
und ob es für die Oktopusse gut ist.
Ich habe grosse Schuldgefühle.
Aber die hatte ich immer.
Die ganze Zeit.
Wenn z.B. das Wasser nicht gut war,
hatte ich Schuldgefühle.
Während des ganzen Projekts trugen
wir immer diese Schuld mit uns,
diesen Gedanken, ob man das darf,
ob das richtig ist.
Ja.
Könnte ich
mit einem Oktopus diskutieren,
wäre es so einfach,
aber das ist nicht möglich.
* Sanfte Musik *
Einen Monat nach der Theaterpremiere
treffe ich Nathalie zum letzten Mal.
Sie hatte sich
ein ambitioniertes Ziel gesteckt:
der Welt zu zeigen,
dass Mensch und Oktopus
eine Beziehung aufbauen können.
Auf dem Weg
hat sie viele Grenzen überwunden.
Dann kam Corona.
Wir konnten nicht wie geplant
in allen Theatern spielen.
Darüber bin ich schon traurig,
wirklich.
Aber es ist nun mal so.
Aber ich bin froh über die ganze ...
... Erfahrung und alles,
was wir erlebt und verstanden haben.
Ich glaube, wir haben
einen grossen Weg zurückgelegt.
Darüber bin ich glücklich.
Die Leute,
die das Stück gesehen haben,
haben mir gesagt, sie hätten
wie eine Reise im Meer gemacht.
Sie waren fasziniert.
Sie haben mir gesagt,
sie hätten nie gedacht,
dass Oktopusse so faszinierend
und schön sein können,
man mit ihnen
eine Beziehung haben kann
und dass sie
eine Persönlichkeit haben.
Aber wieso sollten sie
keine Persönlichkeit haben?
Das ist immer der Mensch,
der so denkt.
Für mich ist es normal, dass ein
Oktopus eine Persönlichkeit hat -
genauso wie ein Hund,
ein Pferd, wie alle Tiere,
wie die Menschen.
So bald wie möglich will Nathalie
Sète in einem Naturschutzgebiet
in Südfrankreich freilassen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021